how to build your own fan base to become
a successful musician in the old days
you had to be anointed are recognized by
gatekeeper usually a record label the
same was true for authors to be
successful your main goal was to
convince a publisher to take a risk on
you similarly visual artists needed
galleries and radio host needed stations
talent wasn't enough in other words even
if you had a proven means of providing
something valuable to an audience you
still had to rely on the powers that be
to help you reach that audience
fortunately times have changed in the
world of stardom today thanks to mediums
like Instagram and Twitter that make
engaging and communicating with fans
easier than ever more and more people
are carving out a space for the
independent fans supported work indie
musicians often choose to go it alone
even after they had the opportunity to
sign with labels traditional publishers
are now scrambling to sign authors who
have sold hundreds of thousands of books
directly to readers to Amazon's Kindle
platform for sometimes even directly to
their own websites the musicians artists
and writers who fly out today understand
that their success is due not only to
the fans which is something that artists
have always said the difference is that
now success is due to the relationship
with artists maintained with the fans
almost without exception those who
succeed in the new economy share for
specific characteristics a body of work
product of ABBA fans the audience a
means of sharing the body of work the
platform and a way of getting paid for
their work the money none of these four
requirements is optional you need all of
them to succeed in the new economy it
can be tempting to cherry-pick an
example of someone famous who's made it
big by emitting something listed above
but those are the very rare exceptions
if you're hoping to follow the proven
model you need all four requirements
[Music]